four states just set a timeline for the
end of their mass mandates in schools
with the democratic governors of
connecticut new jersey and even the
president's home state of delaware among
them and randy weingarten the president
of the american federation of teachers
seems to be on board
i think we have to be
talking about the off ramp for mass and
we
asked for
that conversation that's based upon
science instead of politics back in
november before omicron no one wants
maths in schools not teachers not
students
but you know it's time in this covit
pandemic to actually do a little bit of
planning based upon science as opposed
to just announcement by announcement
but the white house surprise surprise
still pushing for masking in schools
the cdc is still recommending universal
masking in schools that's correct and
that still remains our recommendation so
are you
pleased with it fine with the new jersey
governor's decision
again our advice to every school
district is to abide by public health
guidelines it continues to be at this
point that the cdc is advising that
masks can delay reduce transmission
ask for the kids but not for the white
house press secretary
brett starting with you it's interesting
you have the american federation of
teachers their line seems to be
something along the lines of you know
we're for and off ramp however maybe not
right now but what's curious is you're
seeing all these states blue states
bucking the cdc we know the cdc
previously was at least having some of
these teachers unions review their
guidelines on reopening schools and
here's the chicago teachers union they
reacted friday after an illinois judge
ruled to temporarily halt the governor's
executive orders on masking quarantining
and in part their statement read this we
expect the mayor and cps to act
responsibly and uphold our agreement to
require mass providing can 95 mass for
every adult and child in our schools
this is what the overwhelming majority
of chicago parents and family support so
at least some of these teachers unions
seem to be in line with the cdc as blue
states uh bail and droves yeah i mean
this is not insignificant the fact that
you have governors in blue states
turning the decision making here's what
happened the science did not change
the politics changed and
that is what i think you're seeing a lot
of the places across the country is that
people are saying wait a second
we have now seen study after study
overseas and studies here in the u.s
that say it is minuscule especially for
kids in school
and the detriment from studies including
one out of london says that
psychologically kids are really
taking it on the back as far as the
ability to recognize other students and
to not interact properly
right and julian you know brett makes
the point this isn't about science
that's changed it's about politics i
think that's exactly right um i was
interested in this tweet that i saw by
michelle exner she works for kevin
mccarthy in his leadership office and
she said this did a d triple c that's of
course the democrat campaign's house arm
did a d triple c memo go out today
alerting democrat politicians that
america has had it with mandates because
it really was like domino's you you had
california organ all of a sudden out of
nowhere and nothing changed with the
science
um you were right brett is right to
point out that the science has been
immutable through most of this it has
not changed the politics has changed the
other thing that has changed kaylee is
that we're now getting more information
about the deleterious effects all of
these sort of preventive and protective
measures are actually having on the
nation's kids so the question that
states and cities now have to grapple
with is when do those risks
outweigh the proposed benefits so we
know for example to brett's point about
mental health that anxiety and
depression among children has doubled
during the course of the pandemic we
know that
suicide attempts by young children under
18 are up 51 and landing those children
in hospitals in er rooms nationwide we
know that
eating disorders resulting in
hospitalization for young girls
under 16 have increased by over 120
percent during the course of this
pandemic scientist and doctors are
attributing all of that to the effects
of isolation so this is now the key
billion dollar question you could call
it
that state leaders city leaders and
school leaders are going to have to
grapple with at what point do the risks
the new risks really outweigh the
perceived or proposed benefits for our
kids that's right emily and there's a
new study that brett mentioned out of
london i think when we get daylight from
covid19 from this pandemic what we are
going to see is the absolutely
deleterious effect that this coven 19
mandates have had on america's children
child abuse reporting down as schools
were closed the list goes on kids you
know rely on schools for school lunches
the list goes on and you've looked at
the study it does and frankly it started
spiking right away i mean i argue that
it's actually not a recent risk it's
been happening this entire time we have
watched the tragic decline of the mental
health of our students in our youth and
contrast that with for example what's
happening there in virginia in loudoun
county where we now know that there was
guidance issued to the principals in the
school board there of issuing warrants
for the arrests of youth if they don't
comply with mask requirements it lead it
details a detailed plan of how exactly
to obtain the warrants how to serve via
law enforcement within 24 hours and
included guidance against restricting
parental involvement restricting them
from the campus here's what i find so
ironic we have in that same state a law
passed there that says we have to follow
cdc guidance in school right that's part
of the argument they're using to say no
we have to keep them asked but that same
cdc reports to jillian's point a 51
increase in suicide attempts with girls
alone 31 percent across adolescent
boards we have what's known as a river
of referrals of mental health
emergencies we have the the national
academy of pediatrics calling it a
national health public emergency and yet
this is the same these are the same
resources that the school boards are
using to terrorize the parents frankly
and to ensure the kids are kept masked
now drawing in criminal law for it it's
absurd and unfortunately the cost here
the collateral damage is our students
mental health and their lives yeah and
and you know here's my question for the
cdc well i have a lot
but i'll i'll keep it simple just to
your point are they only singularly
tasked can these people not multitask
like you've got to be able to take a
look at all those categories and figure
out where the harm is
right and this is a mighty mighty
number of harm number it's it's a
percentage of harm that if you had 51 of
anything
that was overtaking a segment of the
population you'd pay attention to it
like if it were covid's evil sister
you'd pay attention to it it's omicron
you paid attention to it can you not pay
attention
to
to
well i guess some people would argue
that teachers
have a problem with our health but we
won't go there right now but but i mean
if if you want to look at mental health
there's that category over 50 percent of
where people are suffering why can't
they take a look at that along with what
they're doing and by the way
parents that i'm talking with and having
on the faulkner focus now are telling me
that this is more than just whether or
not the white house believes in the cdc
this has to do with some of the parents
don't believe in the cdc anymore so
which part of the cdc do you want us to
trust do you want us to trust the part
where they said
you know mass just mass mass mass mass
for the kids oh by the way the cloth
mask actually don't work against omicron
but maybe they do but maybe they don't
so maybe you wear two but then you need
this certain kind of n95 and we're going
to send them to every household but wait
a minute we can't get them to every
household we're struggling with the post
office to try to get the tests out too
and everything else right i mean this
this is less about whether or not the
white house trusts the cdc this is about
whether american parents can trust the
cdc along with the white house to have
their kids best interests at heart since
they are so singularly focused on one
thing and not that mental health
component they can't multitask and
whether parents can trust the media
because this soundbite has really gone
viral across social media this is cnn
alleging that the science suddenly
changed this is their main health expert
let's take a listen
i don't think anyone really is saying
that no one should ever wear masks but
rather that the responsibility should
shift from a government mandate imposed
from the state or the local district of
the school rather it should shift to an
individual responsibility by the family
it's quite a change from dr liana when
harris i also as a journalist just want
to get your perspective on this msnbc
look at how they report when a mass
mandate is lifted in virginia
in his first 10 days speaking of yunkan
he's gone backwards towards trump
experts discuss va governor banning
school districts from requiring mass but
when a new jersey governor does it a
blue governor hears the tweet this is
the right step new jersey governor list
mandate so backwards toward trump when
fewer people were dying from covid
when the vaccines had just come online
and people were actually embracing a
message about being vaccinated to
protect themselves and not believing
some of those on msnbc who said you
could never get it like rachel maddow no
that's not what vaccines do that's not
what the flu shot does that's not what
any of them they keep you they help you
build immunity to whatever it is so if
you get it you stay alive you do better
i mean i i'm confused about where
the role of the media thinks it should
be right i i i think that they think
that they're bigger in our lives and
we're part of the media and i know all
day long that when i go to the local
acme or piggly wiggly if i'm home in the
south
if i go wherever i go to go shopping
people are happy we see each other watch
on fox whatever but i am not the most
important part of their day you know
what helps them if i happen to be in
line and have some facts i can i can
share with them to make their life
better other than that harris faulkner
is just another shopper that's how i
look at these people across channel yeah
i don't want to be too cynical here i
don't want to be too skeptical but as we
get closer to the midterms
this ability to then provide liberty to
then say we're lifting all of this stuff
because everything's getting better
suddenly becomes a political thing and
they're going to try to take credit for
the change of covet whereas
with the data has kind of been there
from the beginning bingo president biden
tried to have that liberty from covid
celebration last july i think they're
going to endeavor to do that this july
just before midterm everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
gonna miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now